-You know,
with everything going on,
sometimes we don't get
the details about everything,
and there's been a lot of talk
lately about 3-D printed guns,
which if you don't know,
are guns that people
print themselves at home
using a 3-D printer.
But the technology and the laws
surrounding those guns
are pretty confusing.
Luckily, I saw a commercial
last night that explains it all.
Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Gin!
-Oh!
-I enjoy
our little get-togethers.
-Well, you know what
I don't enjoy?
-What?
-Not feeling safe
in my own home.
-It's the state
of the world today.
-Anything could happen.
-That's why I'm gonna
do something about it.
-What's that?
-I'm gonna print my own 3-D gun.
-Well, that sounds interesting.
-Wait.
How do you print a gun?
-It's simple.
A 3-D printer
liquefies thermoplastics
and then lays it down
in a successive layer
in a specific pattern dictated
by the object you want to print.
-That does sound simple.
-No, it doesn't.
-And you know you can trust
a 3-D printer to make a gun
because look what a good job
it did on this coffee mug.
-Oh. Now, how much does one of
these 3-D printers cost, anyway?
Are they expensive?
-No, they're very affordable.
-Really?
-Yes.
They range anywhere
from $800 to $10,000.
-That is affordable.
-Are you serious?
A real gun costs like $100.
-But if you're printing a gun,
you're gonna want to go
with a more expensive
3-D printer.
-Why?
-Because if you don't make
the gun correctly...
-Yeah.
-...it could break apart.
-Then what?
-And then explode in your hands
when you fire it.
-Fun.
-Nope!
-Now, is printing a gun
even legal?
-Well, the federal government
passed a law
saying that it's legal
to post blueprints online
that tell you how to make
a 3-D gun, so yes.
But then a federal judge
passed an injunction
saying you can't post
any more blueprints, so no.
But no one said you have to
take down the blueprints
that are already online.
So who knows?
-Well, that does sound
cut and dry.
-That sounds
like an ethical minefield.
-You're funny.
[ Both laugh ]
But, Barb, do you even
know how to use a gun?
-How hard can it be?
I use a car every day,
and I didn't get
any special training
for that or even a license.
-You don't have a license?!
-No.
-We carpool to work!
-You two gals have jobs?
-This is very dangerous.
-Not as dangerous
as not having a gun.
-I have a gun.
I keep it right here in --
Uh-oh.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, well.
-I swear to God, Margaret.
Look, Barb,
this is a terrible idea.
Please don't do this.
-Too late.
[ Printing ]
-Oh. Is there
a Mrs. 3-D printer?
I'll have my very own gun
in just 37 short hours.
That's enough time to beat
you two in another game of gin.
-Oh!
[ Both laugh ]
-This message brought to you
by Big Bob's Gun & Knife Show!
Get a gun in five minutes
or less -- guaranteed!